[Music]
ron funch is on the show not to be
confused with uh ron munches over there
ron funches is our guest today he is in
the news show loot i started watching it
last night with maya rudolph it is so
funny he's always hilarious he is always
uh poignant and uh
i'm very excited he came back but before
that we're gonna just check in because
it's been a minute we've banked a bunch
of episodes because uh we've all been
kind of gone it's been the summer
everyone's gone everyone's noticed in
italy
no one works anymore that's true
literally summer fridays turned into
summer summers
and
uh i had my special come out
give it up for my good friend and yours
[Applause]
yeah
there's a documentary i need you to
watch immediately why are you
complaining about this miracle in your
living room i'll turn this song off in
three
minutes
that is the move that's illegal in the
nfl i would like a big beaver magazine
please
i paid
74 for this bullshit shit we put it on
our face
we can plie down to the spelling bee i'm
on the moon
it's like two crocodile eyes coming out
of the pond it's dark
should we just get in the van with that
guy
[Music]
i feel like that was good
can i have my ring please
she doesn't get it
[Music]
i know can you believe i'm not married
um
emily and i
went on a vacation together
and we have yet to update everyone how
it went um well whitney calls it a
vacation but it was a whitney vacation
so it wasn't a vacation and emily called
it a kidnapping
exactly what it was i got the amber
alert
i tried to text you it was an emily
alert it it really held a mirror up to
me because i did this is i i i have a
hard time with vacations i have a hard
time celebrating myself i have a hard
time relaxing we know this but um i uh
had a show in the hamptons and i'm like
okay show the hamptons
tim dillon has a place there
you know i have a family member that has
a place let's i'm already
turning a work thing into a vape i'm
already that's why i thought we had a
really good chance of it being a
vacation because one you were getting
paid to be there like that is already a
plus right because a lot of times you're
on vacation like you're doing the math
in your head like this this this can't
enjoy it right so we didn't have that
job two we had a nice place to stay for
free that is a family member so it was
like a comfortable nice place so i was
like man we already have two major
things
on the checklist this is going to be a
vacation but we managed to not do it
well how so
well
i think we i have you know documentation
of it in my phone
i'm telling whitney that she needs to
take a break and she's telling me that
she is and this is what whitney's doing
and this is what
i'm doing this is a very relaxing
vacation as of right now let me just say
millionaire not millionaire
not millionaire millionaire
if you were smart enough to steal from
me you'd be a millionaire
i argued that that would have been a
relaxing vacation if the hamptons wasn't
such a hell hole
it's not my fault that the hamptons is a
trash place masquerading as this luxury
resort i'm like go to the hamptons
that's where all the rich people go like
the most
the richest people in the world that
could go anywhere in the world they
choose to go here this must be the most
relaxing soothing
gorgeous perfect climate
no deadly bugs anywhere
right i decided okay doing a show in the
hamptons it also seemed like a good idea
because i feel like you know it felt
like a safe bet it was fourth of july
weekend yeah comedians are getting
assaulted on stage a lot now it's very
sketchy i figured like what's the worst
that could happen in the hamptons but
someone's gonna run up on stage at me
and like throw a tick at my face
run on stage with
you know
i just i i wish i was a i wish i was one
of those people that could run with the
illuminati in the hamptons i'm not a
hamptons girl i don't get it it's where
fancy rich people go like this is like
where very fancy rich people are right
on the east coast it's up there with
like cape cod martha's vineyard and
epstein island
[Laughter]
i also want to preface this which is
this is a rant is coming
by saying that i am actually not like
contrary to what like tim dillon and all
these people make fun of me they think
i'm this like fancy rich person that's
just compared to their pathetic patreon
self that's true okay so i know like
everyone thinks that i have like tons of
money
which is you know from two broke girls
syndication that's what everyone thinks
about but what people don't know is that
syndication money dries up pretty fast
when two of your parents had strokes
without health insurance thanks guys uh
and
a family member needed two new knees
and then when i got her the new knees
uh she needed a car as well so i was
like okay just two yeah i'll get them
both at once you know knees are more
expensive than the car it's another
conversation
but um i know what goes on right in the
upstairs of downton abbey and i'm going
to tell you something right now it's
bone chilling
okay
there would be riots in the streets i
mean if you all knew what the kind of
waste that goes on with richmond like it
is so wild i mean i truly think the only
reason there are not riots in the
streets right now is because the
homeless problem is so bad that all the
trust fund kids that normally protest
they don't want to be near any of the
meth heads which is i did recently get
uh i have to get in a fight with a meth
head
at our hair stylist jess switzer salad
the harlot the harlot in um west
hollywood west hollywood uh she's doing
my hair and this meth addict stormed in
wearing
uh
if i may say very cool cut off jean
shorts
the homeless people ask them where you
got them
i'm on the market i was like give grace
her shorts back
how dare you
and uh
no they were they were even for a
methodical they're probably too big for
you
it always happened wait did you guys
swap tank tops
oh i thought you meant me i was like i
would never yeah he probably is from
kansas actually
that place will drive you to do math
and so
there is a very like uh hot pirate vibe
going on
with the homeless people in la it was
like it was you did feel like this was a
recent yeah like this was a recent
addiction or he's choosing
to do it like he has a backup plan but
he's choosing to do the stream like he
could be playing volleyball on the beach
in top gun
like that type of skinny hot vibe going
on anyway so i had to i had to fight
with him i had to get him out it was the
whole thing meth here's thing i don't i
i've never done meth
i don't think direct you know it there's
no life in their eyes like you can't
scare a meth
head yeah yeah yeah you can't like
there's nothing yeah there's nothing
um you know so i had to go deal with it
and i'm like fighting with this meth
head and i think he had never seen
someone like
go out
unscared of him right right but what he
doesn't understand is that like i need
stories to tell on talk shows
i will jump into any nightmare scenario
because i need content
so he didn't realize what the fuck he
was up against yeah i was like bitch
he's like who's what how who's crazy
enough to fight a barefoot meth addict
in the street and i'm like bitch i have
to do the drew barrymore show next week
i need a fucking story
she keeps finding windows in her
apartment
i have to one-up her
if it starts raining we're making a
tick-tock
anytime you have the opportunity to be
outside of the rain with a homeless
person don't
miss
oh my god the point is
we went on a vacation
emily it was actually kind of funny
because i did
start to feel like day two i
was like kidnapping her and she would be
like um i think i'm gonna go i was
watching the evan uh rachel wood marilyn
manson documentary
you weren't just watching it you i don't
even know where to start with this
because first of all the crazy thing is
that you dressed the part you had great
hamptons okay here's the thing i do
i pack for a vacation right i i pack
right as if i am
katherine hepburn yes you really do yes
right and when i when you came out in
that first outfit that first day i was
like this is a vacation
and then when he's like let's sit at the
kitchen table there were giant comfy
couches everywhere let's sit at the
kitchen table eat dips and and crackers
and watch um evan rachel wood
documentary on hbo for the third time
she'd watched it twice already and then
i would sit there and watch it with her
and we'll see by the time emily came
home and watched it again right and
telling me what i was about to watch so
an hour-long documentary actually turned
on
went three hours long and then she went
did you hear that did you hear that
rewind rewind i was like no no i heard
it
i'm clear loud and clear
and then it was like hot take hot take
hot take hot day i was like it's four
o'clock in the morning i've eaten three
bags of jalapeno chips because that's
the only thing in this house
and i drink a bottle of wine i want a
documentary on you guys watching that
documentary oh my god it was so that to
me like i never know where my ocd is
gonna take me on a trip on a vacation so
oh yeah i couldn't make any plans
because i was like something might catch
my the loop and it was that documentary
you know dominated the whole trip we did
have a nice lunch that day with tim
dillon and ben
we never went to lunch no we made it at
the house we come out that is true yes
but you made work for yourself there you
went you went out and got a wonderful
spread you fed everyone like
yeah you just can't relax which is fine
i might be able to relax the hamptons is
not the place okay it's not it's just
not a luxurious place no you're right
it's not it's i don't look i stay in
hotels almost every weekend on tour so
when i'm on vacation i want to live
like a crazy rotation
i want q-tips in a glass jar silver top
cotton balls in another jar that i never
use i just want to know what's there
that's when i'm like oh this is luxury
yeah that's where my brain goes you
don't have to worry about a thing yeah
this place has handled it like i want if
i see towels in the shape of a bird i'm
like okay we're on vacation now i can
put my hat up that's not what the
hamptons feels like to me okay i don't
it was not there the water pressure is
just like being peed on by a child
i if i am on vacation i want water
pressure that is borderline like
physically abused oh yeah
i want my shower to give me cte
okay that's that it that was not
happening
no where we were no
no okay
it was it's the country it's it's it's
like they call it new york here's the
thing about new york everything about
new york is complicated why would their
vacation place be not complicated so
unnecessarily hard it's not fancy like
when you think you're gonna be the most
glamorous
people on the planet you think everyone
is you know going to be like really
glamorous no everyone in the hamptons
first of all is dressed like an amish
sister wife
okay why are they all in like puffy like
peasant tops like do you understand how
rude it is for the richest people in the
world to wear something that's called a
peasant
like for fun
yeah
they cost 350 dollars isabelle
peasant top like no one we need to addre
wife beaters i don't even have a problem
with at this point there's a white tank
top that's what it's called i don't know
what to tell you right yeah you know
what lesbians can beat their wives it
could be about who knows what i'm saying
that's equality now that lesbians can be
wife beaters i feel like wife beater's
fine yeah sure right so if more women
just beat their wives we're even we're
good it's just hard to take anyone
seriously they're all dressed like
babies that are about to get baptized
i'm like you're an adult don't you run a
bank why are you why are you in bloomers
all the rich people are wearing clam
diggers which is kind of amazing because
the rich people in there like white
linen clam diggers are watching
people that are getting paid minimum
wage to actually dig up their clams
and those people are in under armour
shorts
from ross for less
so the people in the clam diggers are
just sitting there watching like elite
you're dressed at least help them right
right you know get in there the whole
thing i just was v i think i spent my
whole life being like i'm not gonna go
to the hampton until i can like afford
to be really luxurious you know yeah
yeah and like participate no no the
whole thing also is not it's not even
photogenic we didn't even take your
phone the whole thing just looks like a
community theater production of the
crucible the only thing more annoying to
me that when super rich people are
ostentatious with their money is when
they try to pretend they're just
i'm just a country bumpkin
i live in this shack
like you're trying to be humble but it's
just so you're just stealing i don't
know the whole you're appropriating
poor culture poor yeah okay you know
what is it it's more just like cosplay
it's yeah yeah yeah it's like a larping
it's kind of his larping that's exactly
what it is larping like amish people
yeah it's like when rich people go to
burning man you know they're like let's
pretend for 10 days that money doesn't
matter
and then go back to our jobs at goldman
sachs because like that was so
enlightening yeah generally so now let's
go back to money being the only thing we
care about like it's just it's your
hobby is to like be poor for a couple
days right you know and i do find it
charming like i get like it is
charming there's an english country it's
like a dude ranch
yes sometimes some parts but other parts
okay
english hamlet hamlet that's what it is
it's like there's like like
cobblestones english gardens like white
picket fences head hedges and then like
there'll be like wooden archways with
ivy on it there's just so many places to
hang yourself when you find out your
father was responsible for that chemical
spill in flint
i don't know if that's why they do it i
don't know but it's odd to me that
people that are involved in so many
craven corporate things want to live in
this charming little like they want to
go back in time to when things were like
harder
you know
like like to get food you have to go to
like fruit stands on the side of the
road
there's not a whole food like there's
there is
there you you no no they have fruit
stands where so that every people get in
their g wagons
and drive to the side of the road
which kicks up all the dust to the
person working at the fruit stand
you know what i mean which by the way
good for them because they charge 30 for
strawberries and i was like good for you
yeah and but then you realize that all
the people that work at the little fruit
stands and little grocery stores are
like trust fund kids
of people that live there and they're
because at first i was like ooh child
labor cool like i like to explain like
you guys really figured it out but like
building adversity for these kids and
then you talk to them and you realize
their dad is like bernie madoff right
like oh like kids are just working in
these little
you know
for fun for cosplay
but also because their parents want them
to like learn the value of a dollar
before they inherit a hundred billion
dollars i mean so that's like so you're
like remember we were like trying to get
breakfast and she's like what do you
want yeah yeah she's like i don't need
to be here yeah and they're like not
wearing bras i'm like yeah
they're all they're all like young girls
that are like redheads that are in polo
at like polo they all look like the
racist abercrombie and fitch or you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah like truly but they
don't give a shit you know so you go to
the grocery stores which they're like
little um farmer's markets kind of and
there'll be like four peaches and like
three options it looks like the grocery
store from gilead where you're like i
feel like yeah i'm gonna have a stamp
this is where all of the fruit stands
have a very limited amount of produce
uh-huh i had to go to three different
fruit stands for a watermelon
that's like hot well that's just racism
you know but uh i mean i did not see one
black person if i don't see a black
person for like
24 hours i get i started yeah
the right place to be it is a little
spooky you know yeah in that way right
no diversity right to just drive past
like these like fruit stands on the side
of the road with like a g wagon which
we're all just fine with the fact that
that was like the car they used in the
holocaust is it yeah that the g wagon
the father of the g the first iteration
of the g wagon was like the par the car
of the nazi party
look
we didn't decide that
look and they're all or by the way a lot
of hamptons people they think that
they're like you know um
roughing it because in the hamptons they
have their like vintage bronco which is
300 000 right and
um anyway i just feel like if an alien
were to come down and look at like like
a g wagon next to the fruit stand they'd
be like what country
if you just showed that photo
to an alien out of context they'd be
like what war what in asia yeah yeah
yeah what assholes invaded the third
world country something's being
colonized in real time right
i don't know i just i found it i found
it creepily quaint yep that's awesome
yeah it's like a bucolic
with a like a nefarious undertone it
just feels like i it just felt shit it
felt like it was trying too hard
to be this um artifice of the country
you know and that it just felt staged
it's also like in terms of fruit stands
and like the grocery stores that are run
by the kids of the parents that work
there it is sort of wild to me it's just
like these super rich parents they want
their kids to learn the value of a
dollar like i respect that
but they all like have a trust fund
their whole life is ahead of them but it
like does kind of break my heart to look
at them and be like you don't know yet
that your like uncle was responsible
for all those kids with the flipper
hands
like it like you it's gonna be a rude
awakening from this cute little fruit
stand right yeah when you find out that
every movie that mark ruffalo has been
in was based on your family
it doesn't matter if you use a canvas
shopping bag the damage is done like do
you tell them like i don't know what to
find out because you're like i guess you
just don't know yet like you just think
this is all fun and games and fruit
stands
but like
sad
bad news on the horizon yeah oh your
uncle invented palm oil cool
uh
it's also like all the stores they
aren't even real stores so rich women or
men who knows uh i'm realizing if you're
a gold digger now
the glory days are over yeah it used to
be gold digger you get to just eat bon
bons shop all day go to tracy anderson
whatever whatever you do now you have to
have a business like you have to
like rich guys now it's not cool to
marry people that do nothing anymore you
have to marry like a girl boss so now um
there's all these fake businesses for
rich men's wives so that they have some
kind of hot purpose the lobby needs to
take you out of the house every single
day yeah multiple
foreign tennis anymore it's yeah it
serves two purposes right number one to
get you out of the house number two the
rich guys need to launder their money
right in many ways as possible
so there's all these like like boutiques
what was the one where you
embroidered um toiletry kits for babies
like terry cloth babies toiletry cats
toiletries their self-tanner babies what
toiletries do babies have yeah i'm
definitely relieved that i didn't become
a gold digger because now it means you
have to have some stupid business uh you
know but i do have friends that went for
rich guys yeah they had to like be a
chef and like start a blog like a baby
pudding business
you know what i'm saying they had to
start like blending babies yeah yeah
like 100
you can't do it you know what i mean
cannot do it you know i am obsessed with
this because you know some of my brain
will get caught on things sometimes yeah
and i got stuck on the idea of thinking
about this woman who like
married this rich guy and it was like
done yeah i thought she was in like
flint
and then they get married honeymoon and
the maldives come home they go to paris
and the guy's like so
when are you going to open a business
yeah yeah when you get here's some seed
money he's like what to plan eventually
so you're going to open a store right i
mean you love
baby you love making baby
bags
like what do you love about babies and
you love products yeah let's combine
those things like what what do you love
you love pillow why do you start a
pillow store oh my god wait that's such
a good idea needlepoint pillows
and then i was like oh god because
there's all these little pillow stores
in the hamptons there's some fucking
bitch thought she was out of the woods
and now had to start like a pillow store
and it made me very uh uh
uh tickled to think about the slogans
she would put on the pillows as someone
who's like an out-of-touch rich person
because i'm like inspirational pillows
it's always like
like rose all day or yeah yeah yeah home
is where the heart is you know mama stay
in bed right yeah so i was thinking
about what the pillows would be in the
rich women's needlepoint store it'll be
like keep calm and marry alone
keep calm and carry on
but that's just for the surrogate yeah
she gives that one away to put under her
back right
jose all day
rome is where the heart is
where i get away from the kids
see i love jose all day jose all day is
so it's important to come for a couple
reasons not just because because people
in the hamptons they need jose all day
to make sure the windmill
that's just there for show doesn't have
any weeds on it or whatever but also
i think that that's how everyone in the
hamptons doesn't get lyme disease is
they just have the gardeners get it
mm-hmm so they send out a front line
yeah yeah yeah truly the ticks are like
oh we hit our quota this year yeah
because the whole lyme disease tick
thing is
wild in this area the hamptons and the
fact that rich people even go that
powerful people even go there to me it
just is like proof that they are on so
many drugs and so much xanax i knew i
was right about this because like i feel
like the ticks bite the rich ass people
with the xanaxy blood and they just like
they just like fall off you know
because i had a tick on me it stayed oh
it stayed people were like why didn't
you wear bug spray i'm like dude i am so
covered in chemicals at this point bug
spray is not gonna do shit compared to
like the amount of toxic chemicals i
have in my body on my body i'm worried
that maybe it got prozac and just got
super focused probably did yeah yeah i
was like i suddenly have a will to live
i'm gonna hang on for dear life i
suddenly just got really focused and
motivated to see when he's blood
so before you go to the hamptons make
sure you know what's in your bloodstream
because it's gonna get in the tix
bloodstream and then we don't know
what's gonna happen
since we're talking about weird
infections and just gross things i
didn't want to go to any of the
restaurants you i mean she was going to
restaurants at night she was going to
dinner i don't understand why everyone
in the hamptons just rich people in
general they eat oysters like i they
make me gag the smell of the makes me
gag i i
i'm very perplexed why do the richer
someone is
the less their food will be cooked
ceviche gazpacho sushi yeah like what
are you selfish are you getting you have
health insurance like we got like why
i have this theory that i'm always
thinking about their staff
and like what if there's like all the
rich like people chefs colluded
to like brainwash rich people into
thinking that like the best food isn't
cooked just so that the chefs could like
come in later go home
oh my god if we tell them that crudo is
the best food for you and that we make
it better than anybody else we can be
home by 7 pm you guys okay what only
takes 10 minutes to prepare
they're like they're not going to buy
that it's easy
as well just not cook anything
so like i'm like because it's gross
anything that needs that many condiments
is just not an edible food so people
will be like oysters are delicious i'm
like what do you put on and they're like
horseradish butter chili sauce and then
you have to put vinegar on top of it and
then like catch up and if you just die
and you just like swallow it just don't
chew it yeah it's delicious just guzzle
it like this is go fucking direct and
you're only supposed to eat um oysters
in months that have the letter r in it
so really they shouldn't even been
eating them in the summer because it's
like june july yeah you're not supposed
to eat oysters without
is that what the oysters said why why
why
wait what so september october november
december
january march april yeah so may june
july august you're not supposed to eat
oysters
okay so there's no way that oysters knew
about the r rule let's just
right how do we know the book is right
let's go into
imagine the months knowing
to put ours on the end right that feels
like it just happened it's just that's
the way we signify it just happens to be
not the summer but what the chances
someone didn't round up around down just
so they could be like every it's every r
month because they were
i don't know i'm not poseidon i don't
know how the ocean works
you just can't eat them without ours
they'll make you sick but just hold on
just stay with me stay with me but think
about you not involved
whoever came up with that rule
my dad
you know
that they sort of liked the idea that
that thing can be known perfectly right
like anything that fits that perfect i'm
suspicious of well no it's just like a
way to remember it no i know pemdas
no emily i know what you're i know the
point i'm questioning
the whole thing
i don't know why
but do you know what i'm saying yes i
know what you're saying but sometimes
the book is right
what are the chances
what are the chances that every month
that ends in r
doesn't have to end in it just has to
have it
have an r in it
what fucking dork put this together
do you know what i'm saying
what are the chances bill and i i don't
know
an oceanographer why
what are the chances
that every month with an rnn also
happens to only be the months you can
eat oysters
i'm just curious no one fudged that math
a little bit just because it sounds good
yeah all right fine then eat them in may
and see what happens
call me
see i don't
i this you know what this
proves even more how sketchy oysters are
dude well maybe it's because oysters are
an aphrodisiac so they make you more
attractive to other people i believe
that they're in africa and it's just too
sweaty in the summer everybody knows
that
it's ice
ice is really expensive and has been in
the past before modern refrigeration and
the summer months you can't keep them
cold enough to not go bad before you eat
them ice is cheaper in the colder months
and summer is hot
why the fuck are the people that use
oysters they can afford ice yeah these
are richest people ever yeah they have
ice on hand they're right there just dig
them up and eat them you don't need a
refrigerator they're fresh they go bad
the ocean is so cold you're likely to
catch a bad one in the summer and go to
the hospital
says who says pat but do i love shit i
love shit that's like a like a w like a
rule
that was made before anyone knew shit
about anything right and then and then
it stays yes yes and then you gotta go
yeah oh is that what is that true or was
that just
the best science at the time it was the
best science at the time okay you know
we should just okay let's just say yeah
we can't we can't afford more any more
people dying at our restaurant so let's
just start saying if there's an r this
is that make it easy for everyone right
yeah but what's the truth
the truth is
i'm right you can't handle the truth
it's not you don't like you being right
you can come up with it you don't know
that
i didn't answer who came up with it
um i would like to go back to oysters
being aphrodisiacs i don't think they're
aphrodisiacs i think that sailors are
just always horny and they came home
with themselves
it's an aphrodisiac to me only if
there's a pearl in it it's an idea
they're expensive and you're footing the
bill
i don't know i just don't i'm not i i
really bump up against
when something doesn't add up
like that's where you and i differ
no emily will go along
with a performative thing and you but
that's why you enjoy life and i can't
you know what i'm saying emily i buy in
you will buy in yeah and that is the
that is when people are fun and enjoy
their lives you buy in i'm a marketer's
dream dream i'm going you're like i'm in
yeah like crazy buy it
call it drink drink collagen don't use
collagen yeah yeah imagine that's your
guy i cannot
if i can't wrap my head around something
i just i am in a loop until i understand
it yeah so that's my thing with hamptons
if we could all just say oh hey we have
we um
bought this windmill uh that does not
work
from the 1600s it was 40
000 right it sits here and does not work
because it makes us
seem
cool
yeah down to earth then like
it makes it whatever great just say that
yeah what i'm saying but you're then you
but moving through the world like that
is going to be very difficult for you
because they're not self-aware to know
that right well then my brain well my
brain is like what is this windmill like
we just got
like oh it's a like we have amsterdam in
our blood like this is like a like they
can think of any reason that's not going
to satisfy you yeah well i'm just it's
what's next my brain is like we just got
rid of the last pay phone in new york
because no one used dumb right but you
have a windmill
in your yard
i'm just curious what's going to happen
in 40 like what is what's the next
iteration just a bunch of like fax
machines yeah
in the yard why this machine like why is
it algebra yeah it is a machine yeah why
is this the one we pick to be cute for a
photo yeah what technology gets to be
there forever as uh a thing right what's
considered a statement what's trash and
what's not because that's trash right
the facts may seem trash why does this
one get to stay
sane
i guess for me i also realized i take
umbrage at this because growing having a
farm like i've been on a farm you know
in roanoke we had an actual farm and
everything is
necessary that's there
like the screen door serves a purpose to
keep bugs out
in the hamptons they all have screen
doors and they leave them open
[Music]
if i did that as a kid i got reamed out
good yeah oh so rightfully right yeah
yeah you decide you're gonna leave the
screen door open and then we all suffer
the consequences yes yeah wake up with
fucking mosquito bites everywhere so
that kind of stuff just bothers it
bothers me because it's like
you're trying to
calm you're trying to pretend
you're the same as the people that live
like this for real right and it bothers
me
it bothers me like remember when we went
biking down to
wait hold up first of all there were
like four bikes in the house let's go
biking
the wheels weren't not full of air well
that's the other thing i said
i don't know how anyone has a second
home because you have to main by the
time you get there it's just a home you
haven't been to in a year so you just
have to do what change the life yeah
yeah more work yeah so none of the bikes
work so me emily or no you had to come
get us
me tim dillon and ben from tim show like
he's got all the bikes tim is
immediately yelling like
yelling at me he is so fucking mad he
got on some puffy that was like i did
was not had a basket none of it worked
none of it worked oh my gosh and uh i
don't know why everyone's
riding bikes in the hamptons with a
basket on the front i don't know if
that's just
how they get abortions now up there
since all of their husbands voted to
overturn roe v wade i don't know
but
you had to come get us because none of
the bikes even worked but as i was going
to i like looking at people's yards
because it all looks so picturesque like
who lives here i have to know everything
and a lot of the really old-timey you
know they're like
20 million gingerbread houses
hat in the front
i guess the big thing in art now is just
to have a slab of marble it's not carved
or chiseled it's just like a slab the
idea of the sculpture because you know
the david statues in there sometimes
somewhere yeah yeah yeah
we paid for it before it got here yeah
but
like we don't believe in gender so we
don't
imagine we want to wait till it tells us
and so i was just like looking and i was
like as someone that just did
construction i'm like so you have so
much money you just have like raw
materials around all the time like that
most people get it's just like yeah we
just hoard the raw materials look at
your house it's like we have to call
somebody like there's something wrong
and in the hamptons it's like no that's
a statement no that's just a that's
pizza's art could be someone else's
bathroom this is a kitchen counter yeah
but it's just here like we just have
extra yeah right
we're just like taking the earth's
resources and showcasing them just like
so you know yeah yeah yeah we have
access to this whenever we want as soon
as we build another edition
i think i really had a lot here's what i
was saying i think i had a lot of
epiphanies in the hampton show because
it was like this is where the most
successful people in the world go
and now i understand why all the leaders
in our country are
dumb
[Music]
and by dumb i just mean delusional or
what's the word out of touch
because i think rich people politicians
celebrities they go to the hamptons
every year a couple times a year
sometimes the entire summer and i think
this is how they've convinced themselves
that they're in touch
with like
normal the heartland yeah you know what
i mean yeah like they i also because
what they're doing is so
um
what's the word like cote d'in
that they think that they're not the
evil monsters there they're like me like
i'm not an evil rich person i have a
rooster weather vein
that tells me the
spinning like you think i would be
inside or trading my windmill is broken
i need to move in to move something yeah
like i
like
why do you have a weather vane like i
feel like your helicopter knows where to
land
i feel like it knows which way the wind
is going you're fine like i feel like
that's how they sleep at night they're
like how could i steal from my investors
do you think someone who has a screen
door
with little flowers on it and a house
with shingles would do something like
that like no like you run monsanto like
i don't care about your screen door like
like who me i would never go to epstein
island i have tiny fish on my chinos
i shop at a general store it's wild
that's how they think they go great i
know how the country lives i'm gonna go
make laws based on what i just saw in
the hamptons right for the heartland
right like it's not the same i also
think that all the people in power are
neurologically
suffering not only from syphilis because
that is right that is yeah that is real
a lot of our politicians is real in
addition to that we touched on it
earlier but i think all these people
just have lyme disease not that i'm
complaining but no no complaining
i had a brush with lyme disease uh a
tick
uh decided to uh
set up shop
and when i saw the tick don't panic in
virginia west virginia you see a tick
you pull it off you bite the head off
you or you
what uh umbridge um
why do you bite the head off after you
take it
oh you just want to threaten the other
should make a point
like just stomp on it okay all right now
you want you can stomping on it you you
really if you're going to kill a tick
you have to like use it
just right you have to destroy it
somewhere yeah okay yeah but biting the
head is not the no that's just for me
okay see that now i heard that i'm just
going to let it go i'm not going to pick
it up no you got to make sure the head
is off but if i just mean if you don't
have nails or something sometimes like
if you find it in a horse ride or
something you just bite the head off
could you flush it down a toilet no
you could if you want to come back and
go inside your asshole okay good oh
maybe that's what's gonna on with the
gerbils
actually race
that actually i saw a light bulb just go
off look into it i'm gonna look i know
look a lot of us we used to pee outside
all the time
in the woods in the bramble you pee out
there you always gotta check your
crevices absolutely for text i offered
and you said no because everyone already
thinks we're lesbians
but you guys aren't
sorry to bring it to you mommies aren't
together your mommies aren't together
it's not everyone it's just everyone who
knows us but uh so
once i start talking to people about
this first of all i posted on social
media because there was a bunch of blood
and i killed it and then instantly
i get so many people calling me they're
like where's the dick i'm like i just
squished it they're like you need to put
it in a bag put it in a plastic bag and
take it to the lab the lab right right
what lab right like what fucking planet
are rich people on that they're like no
no you have to take it to the what lab
what like you're the scientist you have
where am i going to go i mean i was in
baltimore yeah yeah
you were in the middle of nowhere i
don't even remember talking about even
if i was like i'm not putting a tick in
a bag like does this sound like like who
cares i'll be i'll jog it off
get off you know how many things i've
beat
autism
asperger's
rabies i just be rabies
like i can be there's this little bitch
and then everyone's like no no this is a
different thing okay ticks in the south
whatever
the ticks around connecticut
hamptons
new england where all the rich people
are
deadly lyme disease karma maybe but the
point is i had to go on doxycycline it
was an antibiotic it was like 100
milligrams morning at night puked the
entire time i'm deeply fucked up avril
lavigne called us and was like oh no
while we were listening to her in the
car well okay well that was a nightmare
so we're i get the car grace is driving
me somewhere where do you guys go
without me
it's a secret where did we go i was
taking you to the sunset tower
oh that's right and so we were driving
and uh
avril lavigne's texting we're texting
about the lyme disease saying she had
lyme disease for years yeah right it
came like really knocked out yeah we
missed her
yeah but i i thought she was just like i
thought she was just over it and then
she was like this is yeah yeah i am done
and she you can't function right right
and so i'm in the car with grace and i'm
like available in texas and i look over
and there's an avalanche or a cd case on
my right and she's like oh yeah i fully
have it's like she's just loaded in my
car right now she starts playing it like
you guys went in grace's
[Laughter]
like my two rescue dogs i forgot about
like what is happening i don't know i
guess i just feel like um
i do feel like once i learned all of the
symptoms of having lyme disease it was
like neurological damage you like lack
empathy you can't remember things i'm
like this sounds like every politician
in america
i genuinely believe yeah like that all
of these famous celebrities rich people
probably have some kind of lyme disease
brain damage like if you look at it
through that lens and you go okay every
celebrity every rich person has
languages
doesn't that imagine video make so much
more sense
i think you just hit the nail on that
like you're like oh my god this all
makes so much more sense like remember
when wendy williams wear that sweater
with all the stuffed animals on it
mm-hmm how could we forget dude when i
like was going through that lyme disease
thing i ordered some wild shit
oh i know i see where this spoiler alert
that wasn't the lyme disease
so that was our vacation
yeah does not sound relaxing
the whole time whitney driving around i
don't get it i don't get it i don't get
it
emma she didn't get it
like no no and i'm like tell me how why
don't i understand the hamptons and
she's like oh no no so this is how you
do the hamptons so when i lived in new
york
you would get 45 people
to pool together everyone pays five
hundred dollars no everyone paid like
two thousand dollars and then we all
split a one-bedroom home sleeping in the
bathtub
whoever got to the house first like got
a room but if you didn't get there in
time you had to sleep in a bathtub
for what
for fun actually it was never fun i
actually did have a similar experience
in the hamptons because i was miserable
but i thought i was supposed to be
having a good time yeah i'd split the
everyone does summer chairs summer
friday summer share summer it was a
summer share so you'd rent these like
gorgeous houses because i feel like
people do this in roanoke virginia you
do it in virginia beach because it's in
virginia right uh and you know uh uh
hilton head right here right it's just
one it's just renting but you get a
everyone gets their own room you share
the houses are so
unbelievably expensive that it's like
and then you know it's all these finance
bros organizing it they all work out
like goldman sachs and deloitte and they
were like patagonia vests and like they
make it yeah still be on the supreme
court
any day now um and they make these
spreadsheets like you're coming out this
weekend because you paid for this but
you can't bring you can't come out
fourth of july weekend because you
didn't pay the bonus before this live
it's just like a psychotic thing hold on
hold on
so there's no like leeway no it's like
so what's this breaking down to per
night to sleep in a bathtub i never did
the math i wouldn't do the math i would
just beg my parents for two grand i'd
give it to somebody how many days
well you could you had access the whole
summer right but i could only go friday
through sunday if you would save that
money i don't even know don't even talk
to me about it don't even talk about it
i went every week got so drunk cried
would watch my boyfriend kiss other
girls in the bar i'd separate them i'd
cry i cried in fact when we were there
this past this past vacation here's just
really quick going to the hamptons with
emily is this amazing tour
i threw up there i cried there surely
but
it is so it's such a testament to you
your character because you all you start
with oh god this is my favorite place
i've had so much fun there like you
remember things through the lens of like
hope in a big heart like you're such a
loving open person that you start with
like oh my god it's such an amazing
place and i'm like what happened there
you're like oh like i would and then the
reality starts to set in but you lead
with this sort of
rose color that's why i can't think
about things too deeply and then it
starts deteriorating into this horrible
story that is like the premise of the
movie taken it was crazy and i remember
i just cried all the time i cried for i
would have panic attacks on the train
home it was a nightmare i mean it was a
nightmare and so i would fight with the
girls in the house we'd get you know
what i mean like i just like who it was
just a shit show it was just a shit show
and i like it was a bad i was in a
really bad place and i walked by the bar
we used to go to all the time in
amagansett uh in the hamptons when i was
there with you because i met some
friends for dinner we walked by and we
walked by a bouncer um and i kind of
went up because he was the bouncer that
i always cry into his shoulder like
after i cried at the bar and i'd like be
eating a hot dog that i just like found
it was just so bad and um i just was
like crying to his shoulder and i walked
up to him and i was like hey
will right and he was like yeah and
there was like a really long line i
think he thought i was like trying to
get into the bar but i really was just
like saying hello and i was like i don't
know if you remember me um
my name is emily he goes
i recognize you you weren't crying
and i was like yeah he was like we
always wonder what happened to hot mess
emily i was like oh my god he was like
we thought you were dead
he said that to me
and then
one summer he was like how are you
gainfully employed like can you go do
you go to a job every day and i was like
yeah i have a pretty good job he was
like
you go to work every day like and
sustained full-time and biggest comedy
television show ever made i'm sort of
why it's able to function
oh my god and that's when i was like
this is a dark place and i can't force
myself to like it anymore but you were
that was like you were in relationships
with god you know any place is gonna
suck if you're in love with someone and
they're not ready or you're you know
new york was miserable anywhere you go
there you are i would just pay a lot of
money to be there i guess i just feel
like if you're going through a breakup
or someone's cheating on you you can get
i can get through it if at the end of
the night i don't have to wait in line
for a shack
on the beach right right right so dark
if i'm gonna be in a fancy place i'm
gonna be like let's just go to the
poolside bar and get a drink if i have
to go get in line right yeah for a shack
yeah when i'm looking a bunch of like
mercedes is i'm like this is just
you know what it is the hard things can
be hard the easy things shouldn't be
hard yeah and that yeah you know that's
my motto in life
so you're gonna get your heart broken
you're gonna stub your toe you're gonna
fall and hurt yourself you're gonna get
news your mom is sick you're gonna hear
that your aunt has coveted when that
happens you should not be waiting in
line for a mediocre lobster roll that
costs 12 dollars right
that's cheap for a lobster roll yeah
that's pretty good what fresh lobster
where i put the address drop
god drives me nuts
it drives me nuts because i want to go
like this is what it is y'all's lives
are so easy
that when you have a vacation
you choose to run errands yeah but not
only that you're making it difficult for
the people you hire do you know what i'm
saying they don't give a shit about that
well yeah but i'm saying like they don't
have to go to eight fruits you know what
that's also it that is i just thought
about that not only
are you going to place it on it's
everyone that works for you now doesn't
have wi-fi
yeah there's no wi-fi in the hampton so
everyone that works for you they can't
call each other right they can't make
quarterback
you're making it hard so if you're
taking your staff to the hamptons they
better get paid twice as much
i used to go to the have to go to the
hamptons for work it was a nightmare
but did you stay in the fancy house yeah
what was that like i mean it's gorgeous
it's the kind of house where like it
smells good and you don't know why
everything smells good and rich people
just smell good that's true like rich
people just smell good well because
they're everything's white and like
linen and no stains and the dog always
sits perfectly still it's like it's
crazy it's cause it's a fucked up
breeder dog that can't yeah you know
what i mean i got a dog okay i feel like
i've complained long enough
i'm just getting started
that was my vacation
so i feel really hour vacation
i feel like i'm back and restored and uh
i've now got the lyme disease situation
under control the rabies situation under
control so any other diseases you all
want to throw at me it sounds like you
did like naked and afraid this summer
like i got rabies i got like truly like
monkey pox let's go
please don't get that next next this
fall i am doing some dates i still
haven't announced yet the club dates
that i'm doing just to work on new
material but i'll be in cincinnati ohio
on september 8th at the taft theater all
new material september 9th i'm going to
be in philadelphia pennsylvania at the
miller theater all new material as well
imagine if i just went back after it was
like that didn't go well uh september
10th i'll be in richmond virginia at the
national september 24th charlottesville
virginia you guys know what to do
whitneycomings.net let's go
um okay my brain is starting to break so
um please enjoy the great ron funches
always brilliant always delivers we love
them
[Music]
is back and he's back at it i'm back at
it is that
do you need me to sing your i love it
back at it name of your turn
back at it hitting the room going to
cities doing some theaters hoping this
time they sell out cause last time they
didn't when did they not sell out it was
a few years ago cause it was a pandemic
or was it just a racist it was
pre-pandemic i remember doing the wilbur
theater rainbows and it was half empty
and then i did tj miller's show and it
was completely sold out and he was
half-assing it so i was pissed off
that is so interesting it is so
interesting to me
who sells tickets and why and it has
nothing to do with being known i feel
like there's so i'm learning as a
comedian to not take things as
personally because you know i'm sure
this happens to you all the time you do
five shows in houston
you go to the airport ron poncha hey man
what are you doing here you're like how
do you recognize me with no makeup on in
gate four deep throating and auntie
anne's pretzel but you didn't hear that
i was in your city for a week yeah this
isn't my f i've done my job whose job is
it to make sure you hear about this
i don't know is it the club
the club used to put clubs venues
theaters they used to put a ton of money
into making sure everyone knew a
comedian was going to be there that
weekend but now with social media they
kind of go well it's your thing you know
put it on yours and they'll say send us
a video but then it's like to their
instagram who has 800 followers yeah
eight followers they're all like the the
chef's like nieces like it's not
so i think that one of the most annoying
parts about being a comedian right now
i was just doing a bunch of press
together like isn't it hard to be a
comedian isn't it dangerous to be a
comedian people are going to physically
assault you on stage i'm like bitch i'm
just trying to get the facebook ad spent
to target the people that know me the
hardest thing about being
please if you hate me show up
i'm not going to get salted because the
people who want to kill me don't know
that i'm there
i need a full room to get assaulted in
please
people that want to insult me don't know
that i'm at the house of blues this
weekend
so i think that it's like and also when
you're promoting your tour stuff in if
you do a direct post
for dc improv june 9th only dc people
are going to like it or only your so
then it's not going to get the algorithm
so it's like just know guys that we hate
posting about our tour dates as much as
you hate seeing tour dates for cities
that aren't near you but we have to
they basically have put all the
responsibility to us now yeah it's a
constant it's just i mean that's why i'm
here right you go to where like this now
we're here because we're friends and you
want to see me no and you love me and
seeing me makes your heart expand
whatever you gotta tell yourself and
you're going to offer for me to be your
child's godmother if you want to are you
serious i mean
we're taking monetary offers for sure i
bids is what we call where where are you
at now
ask me if i've ever lost an ebay bid
i'm saying i don't think you have a lot
of tokens you got a lot of little things
in here i think you win a lot of these
videos
called hoarding so how do you pick a god
parent
i don't know me my wife haven't even
talked about that really nothing about
the guy but i assume it's gonna be
family related see that's smart i feel
like it's usually patronizing usually
it's one of your friends that is like
god doesn't want you to be a mother
so you can choose your most barren of
friends yes so you can like spend money
on my kid
this is cool
um but uh interesting yeah touring is
in some ways i think also podcasts
everyone's like we have a podcast you'll
talk about your podcast i do think
there's a little bit of uh
i don't know a feeling i have where
people are like well i get to listen to
you three hours a week i can listen to
whatever i want like if you're in town
i want to come see you but it's also
there's not this like this is the only
chance i'm gonna get to see this person
or hear from this person i feel
i mean i feel like there are certain
people like that right but i think that
those people aren't going to come see
you no matter what i think
the other way that the thing that makes
podcasts so beneficial is that they end
up being like oh i know you i know about
your family i know about your what you
like i know your interests
we're get we're almost closer to me and
just being your fan like you know i have
like my group of my french punch people
who will like these are people who will
fly from like seattle to portland or to
chicago or where where i'm at to come
see shows because they're more invested
i think podcasting has been very
beneficial
in in that way and that there's more
people who are like i gotta go see you
and you know it's really interesting
because i think that um you know your
podcast being so impactful and in-depth
with mental health stuff and you being
so
you know open about talking about mental
health struggles and um getting better
and this podcast for whatever reason i
think has evolved towards
not that i'm not as good at it as you
are i talk about my mental limitations
people come on we talk about um uh
addictions etc and so you start getting
this fan base that is like a very
sensitive
conscious
um maybe maybe a group of people that
wouldn't necessarily go see stand up if
they had or just it's like
and then
now the crowds are like half parkour
comedy roast fans and then half like
people struggling with depression and
agoraphobia yeah and it's like i mean i
know there have been fights breaking out
at shows it's just seeing that
that or it's been really beautiful and
you see
you know i see like a big
buff dude be like hey this person over
here is too shy to come up to you and
it's your book and like everyone's kind
of helping each other you know but it's
been interesting to see
like what the audience is made up of now
no i love that i love let's talk about
this for sure
because i try to tip the scales more
towards
my podcasting audience more towards the
people who know me from other things
because i think it allows me to be more
myself on stage and more talk about the
things i really want to talk about i
feel like
i i mean because i love stand-up comedy
i am a stand-up comedy fan but i also to
me that's like also saying you're a
comic book fan or your thing it's like
it's limiting it's interesting there is
a um
insular group around it and
and i would love to discuss this see how
you feel about it but
um i'd say like in the last like five
ten years comedy was like cool like it
was cool to be comedian you'd even see
these people who would never even come
into comedy
coming in and trying it or doing it you
still get that now in some cases but i
i've noticed at least the online
discourse is now more where they're like
comedy's lame they're like comedians are
lame comedians are
dorks comedians are which is true but
the kind of person that goes on a
reddit forum to call comedians dorks is
a fucking dork no i agree with you that
and i guess um the lame thing might make
it defensive it's more like with the
rise of social media tick tock things of
that nature it's a they feel like i can
do this and because they've it's always
been like that right yes you can do i
could do i could go if i want to i can
go up there and do that too sure i think
that is that all great for michael
richards went great for charlie
going great for t.i yeah
i mean i i what i'll say like i think i
was thinking about this the other day
because i was like you know
i had a little like jealousy pop up or i
had i just shot a special and you know
the feeling afterwards when you're like
it's almost like a postpartum depression
in a way where you're like i have to
start over and like
was that really good or then you started
thinking of tags all of a sudden from
something you just shot or you start
being like is that gonna hold up is that
gonna uh still be funny in six months
you know cause comedy is like i think we
forget comedy's fashion in a lot of ways
you know and it's like what's funny six
months ago maybe not be funny and as
we're all sort of
trying to become better people some
people um you know things might not hold
up but like that's always been the case
i just think that there's just so much
more feedback now like i was thinking
the other day i was like oh the
difference between now and 10 years ago
is for everyone is that when people talk
behind your back you know
we used to be able to go through life
just not knowing what people were saying
behind our backs and that was kind of a
blissful ignorant place like you know
will smith he only heard box office gold
you're the best love you man and that's
most of the discourse but the jealous
weirdos who had to like start rumors and
whisper and be like fucking that movie
he did bombed or whatever it's like now
he has to see that kind of stuff and i
don't think our brain is really wired
for it and
i don't know i guess i just i don't
think i think the more charlatans that
are out there the better the real deal
comedians do and the more clear it is
that our skill is something that's
earned and different and i've seen this
ephemeral rise and fall of people that
get like a ton of success off tick tock
and whatever and i'm like
or off youtube or whatever but i feel
like i'm
at the point age-wise and maybe you are
too and maybe i've just done more recon
on it because i have to deal with some
like jealousy competitive stuff
sometimes i'm like i've seen it come
fast and go fast and anyone i've seen
come up slow
stays there the faster i find someone
rises the faster they go away it's like
long game 101 yeah truly truly but it's
hard to see that in the moment right
when you're like wow look at how many
shows you're selling now look at how
many tickets you're moving and then um
you get concerned about like
the general health of comedy where
you're like well if people go see this
and this is what they think this that
experience is is that that is that a
detriment or is someone bringing new
eyes to the table a bonus no matter
i think that what we do in our
social media presence our stand-up
presence our podcast presence is what's
going to be getting into people's
hippocampus that are going to decide yes
i'm going to go friday night and spend
eighty dollars that's i guess two
tickets to a club plus three drinks plus
parking whatever i think if people can
go i know whatever happens in this venue
is gonna be an attempt at comedy no
one's gonna try to make me vote no one's
gonna no one's going to try to lecture
me about the kids at the border like no
one's going to make me feel bad and
there's
i have no proof that that would ever
happen so there's certain comedians that
even if you're like i'm not going to
laugh really hard at least i can bring a
double date to go see this person i'm
not gonna hear about the president i'm
not gonna hear about trump i'm not gonna
hear about
anything it's at least gonna be attempts
to comedy and i think that that is what
is moving tickets when you just go okay
this is a person that i know is not
gonna make me feel bad or ashamed and
i'm not gonna have to think about my
problems because i think a lot of
comedians forgot the assignment yeah i
agree with that i mean that's what i do
that's me that's what i love to do
because um i agree with you there's so
many comedians where they feel like
um i don't
i don't want to say it's like oh so many
but like there's the thing we're like
well if you're not spitting truth to
power if you're not tearing down the
walls of the democracy what are you even
doing on stage and it's like
the thing that i really
helped me during a pandemic especially
when i couldn't get on stage especially
when i was doing zoom shows and i didn't
want to do zoom shows and i remember
showing up and seeing dave caldwell the
denver super fan who goes to every
freaking show that i've ever done at
comedy works i've seen him there's so
many times he has a shotgun laugh that
people either love or hate and just
seeing him in that zoom and how him
talking afterwards and being like he's
like i used to go to shows every week
and now i can't and i need something to
fill that void and it's like
oh yeah i forgot my fucking job
my job is to make this shitty place we
live in better
and if i can do that either small little
bit for a half an hour an hour 90
minutes then i'm doing something
positive in this world i'm doing
something that is worthwhile and so you
might get up there and be like well ron
just does jokes about rugrats or his
family or butts or whatever but i'm like
for if you come into my shows my whole
premise my whole thing from beginning to
end from my openers to the music
playlist that i pick out before shows
every bit of it is designed for you to
leave going oh i feel refreshed i feel
better joyful i don't leave feeling bad
about myself feeling like i did
something wrong feeling like i vote i
hate the person next to me i mean it
really is
it just it kind of breaks my heart and
pisses me off to hear you say that
because it's like it's never been our
job yes a lot of comedians that we
respect have talked about politics and
social issues but like you know as
someone that is a white woman
even me just being successful without
making statements constantly is a
triumph just a black comedian being rich
and successful
you're already breaking down walls thank
you so much for knowing that i'm rich in
success
like you're like i've done my part it's
all you people that got stuff that you
didn't deserve why don't you work on the
walls that need to be broken
the ones that you fucking parkoured off
of to benefit yourself like why don't
you do that work and allow us just just
to stay focused it's what drives me nuts
when
i always get these fucking texts and
calls from people who are like hey i
hear louis ck's performing in louisville
what do you think i'm like what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do about it
i don't work for the louisville improv i
don't i already have to work twice as
hard to get half as far it's not my job
to deal with the behavior of other
people in my field it's not yours either
and
us just doing what we're doing in an
honest fearless unique original way
that's already breaking down walls
so how about you motherfuckers that
built the walls how about you tear them
down so we can just stay funny
jim saying the same shit that oppressed
it's not you know our job to take him
down with comedy and i guess it's just
it's already so revolutionary for people
to actually pay money to see a woman and
think she's funny that let me just try
to stay funny also it's just a thing of
like
there's only i got only so many things
to think about and focus on at the given
time um you can assume that if you have
a cause that is worthwhile and positive
that i am for you but just because you
don't see me speak about something
within that given week or that hour
doesn't mean
that i'm your enemy it doesn't mean that
i'm like
not for but to
uh
have that louis ck grammy thing because
i got a bunch of dms about that would be
like why aren't you speaking out about
louis ck winning the grammy it's a it
affects your whole thing i'm like
you're not going to get me to care about
the grammys
no matter who wins a fucking grant the
way the fact that i heard about it from
my dms already means it's not that
impactful
if you guys have since when is the
grammy a mark of excellence in anything
people as long as i've been alive people
made fun of the fucking grammys so
you're like oh we should keep what's the
gateway to grammy that means he's
validated by like no that means 80 year
old motherfuckers like him oh it's
whoever spent the most money on
publicists is like good for you like
whatever he's redistributing the wealth
he probably paid a bunch of female
publicists to get him that i don't know
yeah i think though self-righteo
righteous indignation is a drug and the
same way we try to you know be really
self-aware about mental health i think
we forget like i was on this recently
did this press line in this woman
dude it was wild she was from some new
york publication one of like fancy ones
not the new yorker but one that when i
saw who it was i was like you better be
like seem cool
um and she was like doesn't it bother
you like all the negative feedback you
get online
and i was like you know what it kind of
doesn't anymore the only time it really
hurts me is if i agree with it
what do you mean you know if someone if
for example summer to se if someone were
to say like you know you saw your show
whatever in orlando then saw it in tampa
and like the second one you kind of
messed up the timing like that's so
specific no one would really write that
negative a comment but if it was
something that i
hey it seems like you're kind of
overcompensating on this one joke
because it's not written yet so you're
kind of just giving it more energy to
sell the punchline
which no one would say but i'd be like
you know what that's true
that would hurt me
you know but i think it hit me so hard
because i've seen that so many times the
last week it's at the improv where
you're like they're talking and they
yell out the punchline you're like oh
you're not confident in that but i've
done it i've done it the louder it is
the funnier it may be when you're
talking to someone that doesn't speak
english and you think talking in english
louder will all of a sudden make them
learn the language so let me ask you
okay going out on tour when i say
there's a couple there's i would say the
three people i've seen kill the hardest
just in general
who are the people you've seen kill the
hardest i would say name three three
people i've seen kill the hardest in any
room that i've seen any room um
sebastian mm-hmm uh let's see in uh
those in the comedy store or okay um and
no and the main room yeah oh i seen him
like
puppets during that main room for sure
sebastian would be on that list 100
um bill burr
um take notaro yeah of course i'm
thinking okay yes i would add those to
mine i was going for like people i
hadn't like
seen in a while one time was chris
tucker
came to the comedy store and was in the
main room i have no idea if it was just
like a pop-in or what but it was like
the building was shaking and like
everyone's like what's going on and
chris tucker was just like
and then one time daniel tosh came into
the o.r we hadn't seen him in a while
and everyone's like oh let's see how
this is going to go he's had a show
destroyed in a way that like he even he
even looked shocked yeah you know oh my
god i would love
that's like that's such a sweet spot
that's so fleeting that i would love to
get to one day where you're both at the
peak of your powers and popular you know
interesting like a lot of times people
are overly pop they're more popular than
their powers are currently and then a
lot of times people are more powerful
than than they're popular
um but when you get that perfect mix
it's beautiful like that flow state
where you deserve what you have and
everyone gets to participate in like the
triumph and you don't feel like a phony
after
and you with the improv no me i got me i
didn't know the list was continuing
oh that really turned out wow
i saw you killed the improv one time in
a way that made me change the way i
thought about doing stand-up i like went
for a walk and i was like you need to
regroup bitch i was like
i was like this like negative my life is
so hard shit is not the way
taking a break from me making ron
hysterically
laugh
to talk about newly newly is a
subscription service it is a clothing
rental service this is
such a game changer if you're like me
and you buy stupid stuff that you'll
barely wear once
this is what you need for just 88 a
month you are gonna get your choice of
any six styles each month you choose
whatever you want to rent for whatever
you have going on totally up to you
wedding season
funeral season whatever it is
you have access to thousands of styles
for more than 300 brands everything from
party dresses premium denim and
one-of-a-kind vintage pieces that's your
jam
newly stocked styles in a range of sizes
from petite to plus sizes up to 5x plus
maternity they carry labels like for
love and lemons i love them loveshack
fancy super cute lisa says gah free
people anthropology and more fast free
shipping and returns and professional
cleaning
in newly state of the art laundering
facility not money laundering no laundry
for you to worry about they even clean
it wow the option to buy what you love
at a discount sometimes up to 70 percent
off newly has that everything you need
to bring your closet up to speed for the
season stock up on a new dress for every
event without breaking the bank address
your only number once this is like a
miracle it's like it's like borrowing
from a friend but cheaper emotionally
and otherwise yep say yes to all the
current trends y2k throwback sets
checker print crochet without feeling
the fast fashion ick get all of the
fashion that you need while you need it
then let newly worry about where it gets
stored through the spring dream closet
is unlocked it's flexible there are no
fees late fees damage fees or fees to
pause or cancel
no big deal if you lose a button spill
something or just need to take a break
your life needs to flex and newly gets
it
renting through newly means getting to
wear more sometimes 1 thousands of
dollars worth of clothing while spending
way less it's a win-win for your closet
and your checking account newly shared
closet helps curb the must buy something
new feeling you get whenever there are
exciting events on the calendar that is
so i'm so guilty of that while still
giving you new things to wear
newly is already a great value at 88 a
month for any six styles but right now
you can get 10 off your first month of
newly when you sign up with the code
whitney10 just go to
n-u-u-l-y.com that's newly with two use
and enter that code whitney10 and sign
up to get 10 off your first month that's
n-u-u-l-y.com
newly with two u's with code whitney10
newly subscription clothing rental
change your clothes
uh this is like getting cute clothes
without all the shame
love it back to the show let me ask you
because you're uh going on tour
as you're working on this new hour as
you've honed it is there anything you're
like
in your writing process is there
anything where you're like uh
not worth it or oh that should have gone
better and it didn't because people are
afraid to laugh at stuff
uh i mean there have been jokes that
i've done that changed with discord i
used to have this joke
uh about like this three-year-old
neighbor kid that i had that one day i
was walking by my um apartment complex
and he was just in his diaper dancing in
the window and i was like and i was like
i feel bad cause i could watch him dance
all day and
it was like cute and sweet but then like
a month or maybe four months after i was
doing that joke uh the jared fogle stuff
was happening with subway and then that
bit
never hit again as soon as that was in
the national discourse
people were like no we don't joke about
anything like that um and i always hated
that because i always thought that was
such a sweet and and
i hate it when something that's really
working all of a sudden has a different
shade on it because of something
completely out of your control yeah
truly
yeah i hate that so much but for for
in general i just write whatever
is going on in my life and
what i'm into i never go like oh people
aren't going to dig this so i shouldn't
say it usually if it's something
embarrassing i mean i've been talking a
lot lately and it's this was
cause i even put in my bed i talked
about how i miss louie anderson and um i
didn't i wasn't really like big friends
with louie or anything like that but i
always loved this cartoon and then i got
to work with him in montreal and he was
just so kind to me and he talked to me
about how he's like you should have your
own cartoon and you got such a unique
voice and
and then just watching him on stage and
he was just so open and honest with
talking about his struggles with weight
loss and so vulnerable yeah and it
really made me be like oh you need to be
more open about the things that you
struggle with and i i started doing i
mean i do jokes about how i went to
overeaters anonymous for a few weeks and
um so and i don't think i would have
done that if i hadn't seen him and been
like oh this is okay i can talk about
these things that are a little bit more
i'm more self-conscious about but as far
as like taboo
um i you know a big pro wrestling friend
and i liken it to to that whereas like
there was a time if you don't have rules
in a match then when you break a rule
there's nothing to get mad about there's
no no emotional pull to go from if
everything is if everything is off
limits then you keep having to be like
all right well i'm gonna set this table
on fire and i'm gonna set three tables
on fire and now we're gonna go up on the
scaffold and i gotta toss you off but if
there's these things that are considered
taboo and you're able to play with them
because you have a skills then that's
great i don't think there is any
issue with that with the issue that
we've been having usually is that people
aren't using their skills in a good
enough way to but they don't have the
skills yet so it's like a sushi chef or
whatever you know when you cut a
blowfish a certain way it'll kill you
yeah it's like if you've been on tick
tock for two years and you think you're
a comedian you shouldn't be cutting the
you shouldn't be doing holocaust jokes
yet you haven't earned it you're not
mindful enough yeah you're not gonna
retreat it with the respect it deserves
it's like nothing's off limits as long
as you're gonna put a trip i have a
couple bits that i've been working on
for three or four years because i'm like
i know that if i'm gonna do this it has
to be
undeniable it has to be the funniest
most well thought out insightful so that
i'm earning the right to talk about it
so like things like that where you're
like it makes me laugh but i need to
handle it with such care
before i go out with and i think a lot
of people they're like they don't let me
say what i want it's like no it wasn't
that good of a joke and you're kind of
just like we're sloppy about hacking at
it yeah yeah so it's like this thing
where communities look i should be able
to say whatever i want free speech and
then someone says you're not funny like
so no free speech for the person that
doesn't think you're funny and only free
speech for you as you're working out
your new fat women jokes
like i feel like they should be able to
say i don't like this you know i think i
think coming from the roasts also maybe
that helped me a little bit just in
terms of like
you know actually thinking burns are
kind of funny this guy um i started
going through my dms when i went off
tour and um this guy called me a cancer
hooker
made me laugh so
what does that mean i'm nothing i don't
know
it's like when um
uh
no one fucking is funnier when they're
mean than nick sports and nick was like
trying to tell a story and i interrupted
because it was taking forever
and i was like okay so what happened he
goes let me finish you adderall
mannequin okay yeah
yeah
hilarious
so i'm like i don't want to you know i
think if you're not hearing anything
negative something's being said you
don't know about i'd rather just hear it
so that i'm in on it you know
not
me you're talking shit about me saying
that i'm not i don't deserve what i have
and that i'm not that talented and then
i'm just a voice or something i just
make an assumption and then i just go
about my day that's not at all yeah good
people just repeat what they saw someone
tweet i'm like can you at least repeat a
tweet that pete comedians liked so it
makes sense yeah they hear one thing and
you repeat it back and to me it's so
weird because it's a lot of uber drivers
i'm like how are you guys
so into my business that hey you know
you're like it's hard to be a comedian
and b i can take my mask off it's like
all right
thank you covet harriet tubman i didn't
know
my i was waiting to be free
were you in the front seat or were you
covered rosa parks i was in the cold
with rosa parks
baby
but it's wild to me because i do feel
like we've become a species of people
that just parrots opinions that we heard
that maybe did well on the internet
without thinking about it and it makes
you seem smart and interesting but i
mean i can't tell you the last time
someone said i don't know in a
conversation like that i don't know
about it i don't know that's weird i
mean i feel like everyone comes to me
and they know so much about comedy and
what's going on in comedy right now and
you can't say anything on stage anymore
uh yeah look at the ticket sales for the
people that say crazy shit on stage
they're doing great yeah you know it's
usually because i remember exactly it
was the the previous chappelle special
that came out and he said something
about
uh punching down and then i remember
anytime i wrote anything about standup i
would get the some comment going like
you need to do better you shouldn't be
punching down i know with that you know
i know you know what that means it's
like yeah i know what that means
you don't know what that means because
you watched one comedy special from the
one comedian that you know and now you
think you understand my business that
i've been in for 15 years and you don't
and it's also like you guys i don't
think understand how comfortable we are
with adversity like this is where we
shine you know it's like this is not
this is my comps oh the shoe dropped
people are mad and want to fight me
people don't like me i don't like me
good you're on the same page finally
this doesn't feel weird anymore you know
like i think for comedians we're kind of
like whoa finally people are going to
start punching us in the face that's
what we
we say crazy shit and no one was like
when is the damocles sword gonna fall i
if you see the conditions we are in on a
given
friday night
in cincinnati you would know that none
of this scares us
wilson you know i've been to the
sacramento punch line where the green
room is also the storage closet where
i'm sitting next to gallons of
mayonnaise ready to go up to deal with
our audience that's been drinking fish a
hennessy in the parking lot you think
i'm scared of you you haven't been
picked up in a minivan on 420 by five
kids in a fraternity at denver who had a
cooler in the back seat of coronas and
were doing shots in the car and took me
to one of their houses instead of the
frat house where i was supposed to be
staying you decide which is scarier
like there's not i'm just like the
average night of a comedian the weird
emotional interactions we have are just
so much more traumatic than any physical
violence
have you ever been running your hour
right before you're about to shoot it
and there's a woman asleep in the front
row
i mean it's just like i remember i never
had that i had a guy rolling his own
cigarettes in the front in the front row
yes
i one time was i used to tour with a big
comedian and there was a another person
who would feature dana eagle and we were
in uh palm beach the improv when you
used to do shows on sunday that start at
five and it was obviously it was a much
older crowd and there was a woman in the
front row that when me and dana were on
stage
she would look a super old woman after
every joke would look at her husband so
we'd do one joke and she'd look at him
and go
oh and then another one she's like
brutal like it was just like i mean like
the things we've been through when you
think about it are just so wild i i
think we get desensitized because we're
traveling and moving so much but it is
it is bonkers but can we go the other
way can i ask you a question because
it's something i've been thinking about
really
not you're
not your biggest credit not the thing
you're most proud of but
you have a couple of things where you're
like
why why what
why am i here
why is this happening in my life and
this is my career and you have any
i'll give you mine if you need to think
for a second yeah yeah yeah yeah um one
time i just did i think i for i forget
the npr show but this is something where
it wasn't that big but you had like a
but it was like
not even epiphany but just like this is
magical my life is magical um so one
time i did the show with npr in new york
and me and my wife was my fiance at the
time and so the show just ends up being
i forget who there's some um someone
doing poetry me doing comedy and then
paul simon it was definitely unfair yeah
and it was and that was the whole show
and it just and so then me and my wife
got to just sit sidestage and watch paul
simon perform and i'm like there are
some tech dudes who probably play six
figures for this same experience that i
get to just have because i do comedy
also the other time me and my wife did
mushrooms at the wwe no we did edibles i
was on mushrooms she did edibles we went
to wwe hall of fame got to sit behind
linda mcmahon and
and stephanie mcmahon and then we
watched somebody try to tackle bret hart
for real and when you own drugs and
people are actually fighting in a
wrestling event
it's amazing
how do you know the difference between a
fight for real and for not just a fan
who just came out from how do you know
that's not fake though i mean i've
watched enough wrestling to know uh but
yeah it was real for sure i think that
there's also something beautiful answer
my question um
a time where i was like wow this is
magical mine are kind of dorky i feel
like
um okay let me think let me think let me
think because i'm also my brain is like
oh i don't wanna like brag or anything
like that oh you're stopping yourself i
think that it's usually little things
that
make me stop and like
like think like for example like elena's
morrison is coming on the podcast and
she was gonna come on
uh a day that she was performing and i
was like i feel too weird having you
come here and then we tried to
reschedule it last week it didn't work
and it's just like seeing an email where
it's like she really wants to make this
work while she's in town like that is
something that will make me cry if i
like think too much about it because
there are certain people that i set out
being like i want to be the atlantis
more set of comedy or i want to be the
sex in the city of you know what i mean
like just things were in order to
get um to corral my energy into a way
that actually
instead of do writing a million scripts
and writing a billion jokes to try to
service everyone i'm gonna do airplane
food i'm gonna do dating i'm gonna do
that i'm just like i just want to be
like emotional and intense and talk
about the pain in my life and if you
fuck with me if i've you know worked
fine for later so it's like i think i
just have some people in my life that i
look to um tori amos another one and so
when i see in an email like this
person's coming on the show i think it's
usually
private moments because um when i'm in
any moments that ostensibly would be
magical i kind of disassociate
which i don't know what that i don't
know how to get out of that for now
i mean it probably um
just saves you from freaking out right
like maybe yeah i just kind of like i i
but like for example i was just in new
york at the upfronts and i was talking
to jane krakowski who i love
and
i made her laugh like really hard this
is so dorky but i'm she this is gonna
sound dumb and whatever she's a very
good actress so she could have been fake
laughing but we were talking about
getting a dog and do you get it from a
breeder or like you know she was or not
and she was like oh well there's a
certain kind of dog and i was well then
you can rescue a dog
from a breeder
and she was like what are you talking
about well if you go get a dog from a
breeder it saves the dog from
being owned by some weirdo that wants a
breeder dog and like we were just like
laughing about that for some reason and
it was like making her laugh like made
me so i was like this is so weird yeah
the person that is surrounded by some of
the greatest comedy minds like i made
her laugh like that it's maybe more like
that stuff i have those too i love the
one time i made will ferrell laugh when
i was on the movie get hard and between
takes and it just made me
oh yeah it like sent me to another world
because it's so few people can make
those people laugh yeah it's just that's
like that's like the best feeling for me
sometimes it's that or sometimes it's
just like
feeling like you have the respect of
someone that you've looked up to for a
really long time mm-hmm you know like
gary goldman texted me the other day um
john abatto's book came out and i did an
interview for it which was so long ago
so i was like i hope the stuff i said is
still relevant um or even makes sense
but um
you know
reached out gary goldman was like hey
you're interviewing judd's books amazing
and it was like he didn't have to do it
he did you know what i mean that me that
little moments like that mean something
to me fuck with gary going
is that true
he had me blocked i don't know why he
had me blocked and then he unblocked me
but i still don't fuck with you gary
what's going on that you notice that how
do you know everybody because remember
when he was they were like gary
goldman's tips for comedy yeah i
couldn't see the motherfucker yeah he
look that's a compliment he had to keep
you down
you were killing too hard at the improv
no that feels like an accident or why
why would you be i don't know i never i
don't even know people had that happen i
was like this feels like a
something a fishy situation i don't know
what it is but when i see him i really
like to see
i got lots of beasts yeah i uh
do you do you you do and you don't like
i feel like you just have a very
um
healthy joke
talk about your means because
no i feel like you have a very healthy
ability to accept people's nature and be
able to put them in a healthy proximity
to you accordingly yeah you don't try to
change who they are by keeping them
around you more you go you're a once a
week friend you're a once a month friend
you're an acquaintance that's one of my
mantras that's one of my life things yes
i keep people at whatever distance that
i can need you at that i can still like
you so some people that distance is
right here but for some people that
distance is two states away it's a hard
mute button yes
and then how do you ascertain that it's
just your gut or overtime after a second
or third infraction you're like okay
this is who you are
uh
it's just good it's just my god thing
and just me uh gut and then
keeping my eyes open and allowing i
think
especially when i was younger and in my
first marriage and like just looking for
ways to stay in things i would be like
oh i'm gonna ignore that i'm gonna
ignore this flag i'm gonna ignore this
and now i just go if you tell me who you
are i believe you and so that's why like
you um i think she'll be okay with it
but like when my first my wife christina
who i loved so much and when we were
first dating sometimes
not any more than any other person but
like
a lot of women love you you do this
negative self-talk right and i would go
and i had to tell her i go look i go hey
if you tell me that you don't like this
about you or you tell me that you're
trash you tell me this i'm gonna believe
you and then i'm gonna go i don't need
to be around you so i think because what
you're telling me you're warning me is
yes you're warning me and you're telling
me the things that i think about you are
wrong
your first of all you're calling me a
liar and a bad judge of character
and
i mean so many things and i can't
pathologize why
um christina does it whether it's
internalized whether it was a voice
usually that voice is there for some
reason it's a voice that uh you know
materialized when parents or primary
caretakers weren't available and you had
to go like oh well my dad's not coming
home so i must be a piece of shit
because who would abandon their daughter
like it must be my fault like children
can't uh cope with the idea that it
would be their parents that were flawed
because then otherwise you're fucked
it's just too emotional you know so you
go oh must be me i must not be pretty
enough i might not be smart enough
whatever it is but then there's whatever
the the perfectionist
that's what gets tricky is because a lot
of people that do negative self-talk get
really successful like you can use it
for good things that joke wasn't funny
enough you could have done better i
probably could and like that negative
self-talk is super helpful for me to get
better at what i do
but
uh you know and being hard on yourself
in relationships ugh you shouldn't have
said that to him ah you just just text
him back stop being such a weirdo don't
manipulate like you have to know when it
serves you and when it just makes you
look like an idiot and a bad publicist
for yourself and when it's just like a
bad um crutch that never worked like i
remember being
too the two times that uh it
crystallized in my brain that negative
self-talk it does not serve me certainly
not publicly and certainly not about my
appearance was that time with you in the
london hotel when i posted a photo of us
and said that my i have a crooked tooth
and made a
caption about be having a crooked tooth
and you
i've told this story before i will never
stop telling it you were like hey can i
just tell you something and it was just
so like it was like you have food in
your teeth like no one would have said
it in your crooked tooth and you were
like hey like when you deprecate your
appearance like it's just not cute or
you like you know it's like
i won't out who said it but someone in
your life who's the exact kind of person
i would want to like me and and a tune
with and entertain and be a part of
their you know entertainment consumption
i was like yeah that's kind of a turn
off and i'm just like that is such an
old defense mechanism i used to do to
make the narcissists in my life
not feel threatened
and it worked really well until i was
like 15 has not worked since
has not worked since on any level maybe
when i first moved to la like being like
well i'm such a piece of shit like maybe
that was like the men in power wanted me
to be that maybe it did help um and then
uh i was uh talking to my therapist and
she was like so why do you think you did
that and i was like i don't know i'm an
idiot i'm just being stupid and she was
like
why do you talk about yourself like that
i was like oh no i'm a comedian like we
just joke like it's funny and she's like
it's not that funny it's awkward just
makes everyone feel uncomfortable
like and now you're just making me go no
you're not you're the best
you're you're making
me feel your home i've been going like i
believe oh no no no it's like i don't
have time for that
if you feel that way fine this feels
like a better issue between you and
better help like also
i'm big on turnkey person you better
come
healed or have some game plan for your
healing like it's just not it's just too
boring it's too boring yeah at this
point like it's kind of cute when
everyone's a mess and it's like we have
oh when you're in your 20s
my crooked tooth is not a problem
you know and i think that the the tools
that we use to placate others and
you know self-deprecation does work a
lot if you're in an emotionally
dangerous space around narcissists that
need to be the center of attention or
that need you to be a piece of shit in
order for them to feel good or use it
insult yourself before they can get to
you you know it's like comedy like we
control how we're embarrassed you can't
make fun of me because i already you
can't got me because i'm already got
myself you know so
it's weird and i was thinking about you
actually because you know i haven't done
a podcast in a while and i do feel like
you know i was thinking i want to ask
you what you found the definition of
success as of the definition of
happiness because i i recently heard a
good one okay
which is that um from the psychiatrist
that i um started talking to
which is he said success like he's
always said he says success is
the quality of your problems increase
that like that was something that really
helped me you're successful when the
quality of your problems keep increasing
it's not an absence of problems because
that's never going to happen it's always
going to be whack-a-mole but your
problems are
ugh i have a leak at the home i own
instead of i have a leak at the
apartment i rent yes that's success yes
i like that that's great um
i've been thinking a lot about this
lately because of my new house and my
new car in your new league and my new
house
come see him on tour guys
i mean please i need to pay this
mortgage we're out of baby formula
please please come see me on tour she's
got a starving baby
um and i guess i don't have like more a
spiritual one the success this is very
more materialistic success uh which i
guess i'll do the spiritual one with
happiness but i was watching that um i
love lucy documentary lucille ball and
desi documentary that amy poehler
put out with her company
and there was just a recording of an
interview with lucy where she talked
about success and she talked about
for her
success
being
that she had a house or a pool
with a garage that could hold more than
one car and as long as she had that
then she was successful and i was like
that really
freed me and opened me up be like i
i have
the very thing that lucille ball wants
wanted and i have it she got it i have
it i wanted it when i was younger and it
was sleeping on the floor or working at
a grocery store and and didn't even have
my own mattress now i i know i'm
successful i have a house i have my i
got a sec i bought a second house i
think it's important to write it down
because as you get more quote successful
or solvent the the um target starts to
move with you in a vague way because
then you're around people that have more
things so you're like i have a house in
a car if you just go like if i have a
house in a car
i'm successful yeah but then if you
don't write that down or say it out loud
then you're like i have a house and a
car oh god these are so nice and then
you go to your neighbor's house and he's
got two cars you know i have two i guess
yeah well how do i and then it just
turns into this insatiable comparison is
the worst form of violence against
yourself yeah that that leads me to
every comedian now has nine
purple porsches i'm like yeah those
comedy stories
are on a friday night it's a tour show
out there
it makes me feel good i'm like the
industry's doing good even the exhibit
drives by and is like okay
i love that i truly love that i think
it's amazing it's been a long road but
we finally learned most male comedians
are colorblind i told you
um and yeah and so i
if i constantly am doing the compare and
despair stuff and then go back to you
know what no all i ever wanted was a
house and a car that worked and health
insurance and the ability to have dogs
and like to be able to pay for other
people's medical bills if they're in a
jam without thinking twice that's all i
wanted i have that so success is done
happiness that's another thing but
success that's done yes happiness to me
is um a couple of things and
and i'm gonna go in some weird tangents
but
one of the things that i always noticed
when i was
broke and like featuring or emceeing and
i would work with these headliners who
had all the things that i wanted who had
these things and then they would still
not seem happy and there was the thing i
told myself then was like you
need to know when you've won
they don't know they've won they still
think they're playing the game
and because the game never ends but if
you have to at some point be like oh i
won
and like
that is where i'm at now where i'm like
i just want to i'm not even if i never
get another thing i'm fine i want to
maintain the things i have i love my i
want to maintain my family i want to
maintain my house i want to maintain the
career that i built right now if i never
get more famous
that's fine because i'm in a i'm in a
really good spot that's an amazing
feeling um i get to do whatever i want i
get paid a fair amount i think
and from and i can still like a lot of
people don't even know what i do a lot
of people is you know you go like oh
you're rich and successful there's some
people i show up at places they don't
know
you know they think i'm
crew or yeah yeah you know and that to
me that's perfect because i get real
reactions i get to see how people really
respond to me i still get the freedom to
um i get to work at these amazing like
any job i have i love i don't do any
jobs the last three years i mean have
taught us a lot but i definitely think
last year i've shifted into like oh
wanting to be like famous like i feel
like
we're in a sweet spot that it's like
you get the benefit to tour all around
the world meet people entertain people
connect with fans that are like you
changed my life every line of the books
underlined they know ever they've made a
shirt for you like that's the best
feeling in the world i think on some
level like i'm santa claus to this
person like i'm making this person's guy
fieri yeah again
i'm someone's chris angelo you've met
guy for harry i think i'm about saying
his name right i don't think so oh my
god he is santa claus yeah i saw gordon
ramsay at something recently it didn't
go great
when you meet guy
he just makes you feel good he makes you
feel happy love that guy he feels like
he's like the bird chrysler of food yeah
well
he's always just like he's just a
positive energy guy but i do think that
there's an addictive personality that
that makes it so you get to this point
to have this conversation at all and
then you have to know when to call it
you know it's like an addictive
personality which is one too many a
million not enough right i got this
thing well now i need this thing now i
need that you know and how your dopamine
receptors aren't going to hold dopamine
i think that really helps when growing a
business because the addicts really do
win in a lot of ways but then you got to
know when it's not serving you anymore
and you're like no this is kind of just
workaholism and like now it's about
quality and you have quantity you're
running yourself in the ground you're in
order to you're thinking about flying
all the way to new york to go do wendy
williams with your friend on the last
minute notice just because
you think that's going to help your
career when odds are you probably should
just go to bed and stay talking about it
you watched it you loved it
someone's someone jealous over here
i know that was everybody's thing
they're like why are you doing that but
it was like kind of a thing i mean i had
like i'm talking for you asked me to go
i thought you meant the fact that i
guess hosted it i think you should get
it i guess and i was just like i was a
new audience calling all my friends to
do it and i was like come on get on a
plane your wife is 79 weeks pregnant
it's fine you'll make it back
jet blue two hours in two hours out yeah
300
let's go and that was a good place for
me mentally that i said no
that's how i know i'm doing them that's
pretty why when you're able to say no to
things and not do them out of
desperation because you know
if if this is right i'll do it later
when i'm
have the bandwidth for it where i'm not
gonna rush and just be
you know resentful and not the best
version of myself exactly you're one of
the most sagacious people i know
um and you're great at reading people's
characters which is why i'm constantly
stunned we are able to be friends
what when you just were talking about
red flags like what as your like mental
health journey has become a red flag
because something that you said earlier
about like i know the proximity to keep
people i believe i'm now at a point
where my recovery self-help all of it is
starting to backfire because i can make
so many excuses for someone's behavior
to the point of where i allow them to
stay close to me i'm all i'm her people
hurt people but they did the best they
could with the tools they had we figured
others not because they deserve
forgiveness because we deserve peace
and then i'm able to like
use all that self-help stuff to keep
myself in a dangerous situation
how do you balance knowing why people do
what they do
and seeing what's go without allowing it
to harm you oh i mean it just comes down
to
simple self-preservation at the end of
the day whereas i agree with you with
all that stuff hurt people will hurt
people
people dealing with mental illness and
and
a lot of things but
at
the end of the day
nothing that you are going through
nothing that you
are dealing with
allows you to hurt me
so
if
you can't deal with what you're dealing
with without hurting me i just have to
remove myself from this situation
and that that's how i look at it that's
how i deal with even like i remember
years ago i got into a little online
thing and some lady
um
was trying she like was kind of like
trying to drag my name through the mud
because i had taken my mom on at
midnight for mother's day and she was
like
uh it was me and a couple other dudes
and i guess one of the other dudes i had
gone on and on a couple dates with this
lady and so is another dude on the at
midnight panel and she goes like oh how
how ironic that the last couple of dudes
that said that they only wanted me for
their but my body are on at midnight and
with their moms and then and i go and so
then i was like hey
that's not how our interactions went at
all i told you what i was going through
and where i was in my career in my life
i was looking for a girlfriend i was
looking for a wife and i said if you are
interested in me
like a relationship like and you don't
have those feelings towards me
i don't want to hang out with you like a
friend i'm not looking for a friend i'm
looking for a girlfriend i'm looking for
a wife so i'm like i'm not going i love
it that's all a woman like
stereotypically wants a man to say and
they say it it's like well you just want
me for my body it's like i'm saying i
want a wife if it's the opposite of
being a scholar i'd say i'm not gonna go
and hang out with you and what
she'd be like uh
this is a hot tub party i know about why
the fuck am i gonna go hang out with you
at a hot tub party
and so i glitter ass up on twitter and
then people were like oh i looked to her
tweets she's she's not doing well why
would you do i go i don't care like
that's fine but you don't just because
you're hurting doesn't mean you get to
attack me i'm always going to go in and
defend myself and hopefully a you know
sophisticated fact and guess what the
reason that you keep acting like this in
a histrionic way where you're throwing
grenades around with people's
reputations with some pretty serious
allegations in front of their mom no
less like the fact that no one has
retaliated or stood up for themselves
that's enabled you to stay using this
coping mechanism that is abuse so it's
also like whenever i need to stand up to
something like that where i want to just
go like ugh
don't just do something sit there sit on
the bench choose your battles like that
was a battle worth fighting because i
also can go hey
you know this might make me look like a
bully or whatever but the reason you
keep doing this to people is because no
one's giving you a consequence because
they're afraid because you're mentally
ill and we all have to teach you treat
you like kid gloves and walk on
eggshells but like that's just making
you sicker and more dysmorphic and
delusional and i'm not gonna participate
in that no you know i'm not gonna enter
into this reality where everyone feels
sorry for you because you're a grown
adult yes fix it yes or do it alone on
your own time just don't drag me into it
exactly that's all
okay well however you do it just leave
me alone all you want yeah
don't involve me exactly i got my own
struggles that's really fascinating so
what are just some
like
like red flags in people now
when you're thinking about taking on new
friends and now you're married now so
you can say in dating no matter how
shallow it is no matter how bad it
sounds
like like for example if you're on a
first date and a girl says can you take
a picture of me
[Laughter]
is that a red flag that's fine turn off
really that's fine well like like what
do you mean just take it like she likes
the place with a antique camera
is this portland oregon then it's fine
what do you have to get under a curtain
and then it's too much
powder
so no hipsters
like here are the my little pet peeves
okay when i meet new people and you
bring up a show and they'll be like i
don't watch tv yeah if it's some
as if you read 50 books just by saying
that you're not bad like things like
that like little things that as i get
older i'm like little cues that mean
bigger things yeah the person who needed
to stop a fun conversation where
everyone was talking about ozark and me
or whatever you don't have to like the
shows but just like i don't watch tv
yeah and you're like
oh that's definite
totally it's just like a dis because at
first it makes you go oh this person
must be cooler than me because they
don't watch tv and they are busy and
that doesn't mean they're using their
time learning other languages
probably doing drugs
uh if they're mean to the weight staff
at a restaurant that's always a super
big red flag
um if they not funny that's a big red
flag for me but funny on purpose is
sometimes a lot yeah that's true trying
too hard to be funny is a lot naturally
funny yeah you gotta be naturally funny
um it comes with friends or like
business people oh business people
that's a good one yeah you're about to
interview assistants yeah
um and then just lately like um
there's some dude who just hit me up and
he was just like
he
threw my cousin and and so that was
already a red flag and
he was like
man i've been doing comedy for for so
many years
and i just don't feel like i know the
right people i was wondering if you
could help me out that's a red flag
that's a big red flag right there just
coming to me out of the cold calling me
not even being like
i think you're funny or this or that or
what are you doing or you got any advice
but more like
to me what they were saying was
oh man i've been doing comedy i think
i'm better than you but i don't know the
people that you know can you introduce
me to the people that you know so that i
could take them from you it's a tricky
thing but i find like you know the other
night after shows when i do like the
little meet and greets i a lot of girls
will come up they're like i want to be a
comedian and then i like the other day
saw a girl in uh tysons who was like i'm
a comedian and i was like come tomorrow
at huntington and do five minutes and
she did and she was great
you know um meg's uh fritz frizz
fritz i said it wrong twice whatever she
was excellent and um
and like
i and then i'm in the car my opener's
like what are you doing and i was like i
think that this is what we're supposed
to do with our yeah power i agree with
you you
know you have that turner moment get up
here babe but that's like that's
different because that's someone who you
ran that's like in your natural movement
you ran into this person totally times
up but when someone's like reaching out
to you joe online are even like they're
not easy for me for free yeah well i
mean
that would be great i want to see you
know what hey i want to skip to the head
of the line i know you did it the hard
way but can you help me skip to the head
of the line exactly it's what they're
asking exactly can you go buy me beer
like whatever it is and you're kind of
like i don't know if it's their job to
be less entitled i think it's our job to
just be more like meh that's what that
is yeah when i was starting i was
desperate and would ask crazy desperate
shit i mean true you know i mean like i
emailed cat williams i i emailed demetri
martin how did your cat williams email
god i'm just like i'm a big fan of you
mr williams i probably called him mr
williams and was just like i love your
comedy i just just asked him for advice
i wasn't asking him to like for a set
time or anything i just asked him for it
i was like i'm trying to start comedy
he's asking for a bite he never wrote me
back but i still look at williams he's
the best um i
also feel like when people come up to me
and ask for advice the way they ask
tells me everything i need to know if
it's like hey i've written these five
scripts can you read them where it's
like all of a sudden it worked for you
and this i'm like this person is
can't read a room therefore you can't be
a good comedian
if you don't see on my face that i would
rather blow my head off
than hear about your scripts then you
can't do this there's no i already know
they suck
because you can't write a scene about
how to walk up to a professional
comedian and not waste their time you
obviously aren't a writer you're not an
actor you're none of these things
because you can't act like you have
something to say to me and you know how
to do this you know so
when people come up to me and they're
like
hi
and they are like i'm like i already
like you if they're like
kind of
nervous about saying something i'm like
you're already on the right track you
should be nervous that's a normal
reaction but they like have something
prepared they're like no no you seem
busy i'm like you're right i am you can
see that i are we're already living in
the same reality
and you're willing to push through your
fear and shame right now to just
like do your mom's spaghetti moment
and then if you have one succinct
question not like hey how do i get into
comedy i'm like
you two i i don't know yeah and i have
to it's like i could i could have told
you how to get into it 20 years ago
today there's no less than 400 podcasts
for free on the internet right now where
i talk about that and all the people
here talk about it so don't ask how did
you get into comedy you just are doing
the you know i mean you asked me to do a
podcast for you for free and you have no
listeners like now
now no call me when you're the sidekick
on h3h3 i'll come tell you that story
but if someone comes up to me and it's
like hi um i've written the script is
there an agent that i should send it to
and it's like a specific question and
i'm like i already know you're gonna get
everything you want cause you prepared
so much for this interaction and are
terrified to ask me you're fine just
keep doing what you're doing like you
don't need my help you're going to get
what you want mm-hmm you know yeah and i
can't really help you whatever like
exactly that's yeah that's my idea
just expired
like i think i think i just heard some
weird news about quibby
i have to send a fax um but yeah i think
that they're also they're i feel
sometimes pressure to like help but i've
learned the hard way sometimes helping
isn't helping that's codependent if
you're gonna if that that person
that is going hey can you help me out if
you do help them
it's that's just the beginning of many
more inappropriate questions yeah it's
never like oh yeah here's the advice and
then it's done and the person takes the
advice like wait a second so i called
that person you told me to call and they
like got a voice machine now what do i
do yeah can you drive me to the
appointment and you're like wait what
some people are like that though like um
i mean some people just need a like
um and i think what i've been lucky with
my whole career is that
i've been
around the right people i never had like
shitty management i never had like
third rate i mean second-rate agents yes
but never third-rate agents
what up stu you bitch
i'm obsessed with this like what are
things emily what are things that
have been uh red flags lately that i've
been picking up on
people who feel that people who try to
trauma bond too quickly
people who try to get too close too
quick for sure that'll get me dude
that'll get me i'll i'll take the bait
normally when someone wants to dig right
into i grew up in alcoholic home and i'm
sober and i just went into 12 stars and
you're just like too much too fast yeah
oversharing over sharing
that used to be a let's go for a hike
yeah you know well i mean to me it's
like
if
what would that person be like if you
saw their stand up back you like damn
you don't even say hi how are you guys
doing tonight
you don't want to know where anyone's
from you don't even know if there's any
birthdays
we're just jumping right into it
dude the first
10 seconds on stage is the most crucial
mm-hmm do you think yeah i can usually
tell if i i mean
usually with my voice i can tell if i
might have a good set by
like the first because if i know if i'm
gonna have a great set if i go hi and
people start laughing
then i know i'm like oh this is gonna be
easy
this is gonna be fun so that's how i
start my sets every time if you come see
me anytime try that
say hi to them
can i say one more that's weird yeah
people that okay it's tricky now because
i mean i'm the first person to say get
everything you want go get on a reality
show do
maybe the amount of time it takes to get
successful is changing
as a comedy actor as a comedy writer as
a filmmaker not as a stand-up comedian
that won't change i'm sorry it's like
saying that that social media and tick
tock is going to make you a better
professional athlete if you're on you
know what i'm saying it's like the ten
thousand hours yeah you just it's a it's
a skill you can't fake you know nobody
is like drafting
kids that are 18 that play basketball
just because they've done it more on
tick tock it doesn't make them a better
when the rubber hits the road no it just
makes it that you have easier access to
creating a fan base but it's
it takes the real skill set in the craft
to maintain a fan base and maintain
a career and takes years i mean louis ck
always said he's like if you do the same
material twice in the same market
they won't be mad they won't you know
throw tomatoes at you but they won't
come back next year they'll be like love
that guy he's funny but i'm not going to
spend the 300 door-to-door so like but
he was cool with the masturbating thing
though he was like you could do that all
you want
you just can't you just you just gotta
make sure the material is fresh
i don't work in an office with this guy
in new york the italian restaurant and i
order the most incredible pasta on the
planet and someone's like hey you know
the boss is kind of a weirdo i'd be like
can i just finish this
and then i'll i'll unfollow you i just
feel like that's not my
problem i feel like i should be able to
enjoy my night out yeah i don't work
here yeah it's not my i'm here for two
hours
it's not my problem but i understand why
people that don't work in comedy like it
doesn't seem like he does it at shows
like it doesn't apply to me i bought
these tickets eight years ago for my
fiance can we just go to a fucking show
your shows is just dylan's candy bar no
hair
candy you know what i was gonna say
hersheypark and it felt racial
i do want to do a theme park at one
point oh my god that's my ultimate goal
in life is to have like a theme park
where people can come and it's like a
social content farm so you can come
you'll get you have green screens and
like setups of every holiday of the year
so you come with your family we're going
to knock out easter we're going to knock
out
st patrick's day we're going to knock
out your holiday card we're not getting
your thanksgiving card valentine's day
like you're going to get it all
in one day they're doing meet and greets
every comedian you're at home with your
family but you're making money doing
meet and greets in vr or 3d all over the
country you're doing 90 corporate gigs a
night in your bed oh from your bed it
sounds like hell no
[Laughter]
do you ever think about like other
businesses where you're like yeah i want
to make an artisanal ice cream truck
that sells homemade choco tacos and
things of that nature push pops but made
like
like natural ingredients and then you
play fun songs in your ice cream truck
that's i would like to get it on the
ground
that is a billion dollar idea
i feel like people want homemade you
ever had choco tacos are great but you
never had a fresh one in no life never
no okay do you remember
the ones that were um it was like a
there was one there's an american flag
popsicle mm-hmm it was like a red white
and blue and then there was one that was
chocolate and banana and chocolate that
was my favorite and i can never find it
yeah or homemade habit yeah or like
those chocolate chip cookie sandwiches
if both the cookies were freshly made
exactly
yeah with a strawberry shortcake bar
[Music]
it's gonna be very good on the outside
that's fine
people paid twelve dollars for one side
of a bagel
exactly this is it people will overpay
there's a place in um
uh
tempe improv i think it's tempe i fly in
a day early because there's a popsicle
this woman that does a popsicle stand
and it's all these like wild flavors
it's like elderberry lavender like she
like coffee like
like tarragon it's like all these like
weird ass flavors and i go and i just
will go i'll get two take a walk come
back at two
it's like i'm probably her sole investor
yeah that's like me in italy i love a
good or not a great did you just go to
italy
um not just last summer yeah yeah
that's when i impregnated my wife okay
she thinks it was an amalfi i'm pretty
sure is when i was on mushrooms in
amsterdam it was definitely not in her
mouthy
[Laughter]
it's stupid funny italy is one of the
few places that i feel like lives up
and then i'm like this is so expensive
it's so beautiful i will come back yeah
most places in paris i'm like i get it
have you been to amalfi yes it's so
beautiful it is
shockingly beautiful and one of the only
places on earth that i don't mind there
being people around because they're all
so
dressed
as they should be for the occasion right
we say beautiful hotel santa cantorina
and uh when you know it's a great hotel
because it was just full of 60 year old
white dudes in their 20 year old dates
i don't think it was a date but okay
that's very sweet full girlfriend
experience in italy
it's so italy dave
you're a
prisoner uh yeah but yeah that um uh
amalfi is so gorgeous a friend of mine
got married in revello which is like
on a cliff um and it's so beautiful
you're like this is one of the few
places where it beats the screensaver
yeah i went to ha long bay in vietnam
which was my screensaver for the longest
time i always wanted to go and i was
like
yeah saver was better i always wanted to
go to nice because i liked the look of
the the sparkly water beaches on the
pebble beach and then i went there and
it was like yeah this is even better
than
what you thought it really it lived up
to it yeah there are a lot of places i
go where i'm like
yeah i feel like they use the nashville
filter and they hoodwinked me
like ah damn it i've bought it hook line
and sinker
there's something i'm like really
getting into like nature shit like
beautiful shit that is just like
incontrovertibly incredible yeah that's
good and things you can't turn into a
business that's good too or write jokes
about like you'd be an asshole if you
made fun of a waterfall
you could do it
where do you think you're going
water you got nowhere to be
such a rush look at all this suicidal
water yeah
i can imagine yeah you know it's white
water
only white water would want to jump from
that
see we did it i just went to niagara
falls with marilyn rice cub and we were
all the entire time i was like i don't
get it there's no jokes about this it's
just beautiful let's get out of here
she's looking great i like her
post-divorce look she's real like she's
the best she looks great she's the best
she is the best i know you have a child
anything else any other red flags any
other i know you have a child
what segways when people have kids i'm
like it's been two hours are they gonna
die soon if you don't got
when people have new children i either
ignore them for like two years and
they're like what the fuck and i'm like
i was trying to not add to your plate or
they're like yeah i've been staring at
something that can't talk or remember
what i'm saying i would love to have an
adult conversation yeah i know this is
nice i like it it's fun and then okay so
i want to know then let's really quick
so let's end on a bit that you're
working on that you haven't fleshed out
yet or one that you're just like oh
there's a thing i want to work on it's
in the back of my head um
i mean i just want to work on bits about
just kind of the difference between
having a kid now between my first uh
that's good you know to feel like the
toys you have to throw out from the
first kid like like the blond arts
didn't make it mm-hmm that's a way to
poo and then no it was more the fact
that i had
i'm 39 and having this kid and i had my
first son when i was 19. oh i think
there's something funny about the
difference in toys like all the tours
toys for your first kid have now been
recalled yeah yeah
no i mean just most of it the way you
sleep is different now that is so funny
the way a kid sleeps
yeah no there is funny thing like just
sort of like how but just like yeah the
things that you were doing that were so
dangerous didn't realize now it would be
a child abuse yeah exactly that's really
funny to me yeah it's working on stuff
like that just about how the difference
in like and just like the reaction was
different between telling my mom that
i'm having this kid now before telling
her when i was 20. yeah yeah
and then what about the actual birthing
process were you there i was yeah yeah
uh it was fine my wife was a freaking
warrior she was great she was she she
nailed it she
i
i was very proud to be her husband
because i was just like look at you and
then she was just
up and helping the baby like right away
it was really uh
like i was screaming at her to get up
i was like i don't want to do it
i'm playing a video game my assistant is
my assistant it's very unprofessional
to get involved we've had that
conversation
i could ask her to make you a smoothie
but you cannot
it's very unprofessional
that's right there holding
my only job i mean that's really i it's
a fun experience i think um
going to a birth is one of the few times
as a man where you
really um
there's like a lack of the patriarchy in
these like delivery rooms so then you
suddenly are like oh everywhere else i'm
so important i'm in charge people come
to me and then in the delivery room like
they know no one even asked me my name
they just were like oh hi christina oh
hey dad you know it's just like they're
like what do you mean
maybe
exactly
what you did with her they're like you
know what you need to hit this button
and then when you when they're like
there's this chair we think it folds out
oh you sleep here oh my god
you're gonna be in the way yeah it was
really interesting in that regard where
i was like oh they don't give a fuck so
she could probably do this in the woods
without you yeah yeah it was really fun
i really um if you could get out of the
way yeah we'd appreciate it there was a
lot your services are no longer needed
they're out of the way you've done your
job you did your job 10 months ago and
yeah amalfi and now it's uh yes all
right yeah or absolutely
that is wild to think about
i love you let's talk about your tour
dates kansas city comedy club uh they
still smoke inside there i think i think
so yeah yeah yeah and um
august 25th through 27th san diego which
is also la take a trip
drive down south have a road trip go get
a burrito listen to one of those uh
horrible mixes you made
[Applause]
um i love you anything else
apple
tv plus that's the name of that network
right yes apple tv plus i'm in a show
called loot uh with my rudolph is the
star
um michaela j rodriguez who is amazing
and posed and just a wonderful person um
joe kim booster nat faxon
uh
stephanie stiles and megan fay uh just i
play um i play my rudolph's cousin she's
the ex-wife of the richest man in the
world uh so it's like he's like she was
married to jeff bezos they get divorced
and then now she's she's she's living
her own life that's such a good idea
such a good idea does she
does she use all the money to seek
revenge on him or no she used she goes
she owns a foundation i don't want to
give away too much but she's got a
foundation that she probably has not
been to or paid any attention to
forever but now she's using it to find a
focus in her life and so we're going to
follow that journey to see where she
goes
and what she does with all that money
does she get involved in the ukraine war
it wasn't when we were taking not there
okay
i'm just saying
um all right i love you so much love you
too it means good to see you thank you
for coming on you got a normal hair
color now
for you for who knows how long
i think we're out of the woods i think
we're out of the woods of the covent fog
you guys sleep sleepover's over i think
i
very strongly felt like i had to be an
adult way too young and had to be a boss
before i was ready and so when the
pandemic happened i was like oh those
years i lost to play i'm gonna take now
and it's over i'm back to being um
trying really hard to get
white men in our business to want to
fuck me
me too
don't worry i'm being a good girl
i saw what happened to courtney love it
wasn't pretty
i'm back playing by the rules i'm like a
handmaid that got sent to the colonies
i'm like i get it now i got it no we're
back
blessed be the fruit may the lord open
dude i learned my lesson in the comment
section
i love you ron punches
um getting better
started at any time is it giant i mean
how many episodes that podcast 190
something anytime anyone
anything talking about better getting
better taking care of yourself self-care
there's no uh wrong episode to start on
it's a good podcast please check it out
we did an episode with cameron esposito
recently i really like yeah she's
wonderful she did a great job we just we
hadn't talked to her in a while so it's
nice to reconnect
um i've been moving so we've been doing
a bunch of best stuff so oh nice job
um i love you guys uh uh instead of
getting that summer bikini body maybe
get that summer
mind
there's something there hold on what is
it hot what is it summer body hot girl
bikini hot girl summer how about this
fall stable girl summer
emotionally stable girl summer i'm in i
feel like i'm on to something i think
that's good for everybody workshop yeah
i love you guys all right
goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]